okay so the first game of the Stream
it's a rapid Shield Arena if you're
watching on Twitch hello
a lot of people here already if you're
watching the future on YouTube
I'll probably post this whole tournament
to YouTube
this might be a very short first game
oh no my opponent I just one in one move
Bobby Fisher was right E4 Best Buy test
that was uh
mathematical proof
foreign
also if you're watching in the future on
YouTube you can come over follow on
Twitch this is where I live stream
I might consider doing a live stream on
YouTube
um
because twitch recently updated their
partner contracts
so maybe that's something I'll consider
doing like towards the end of the the
year or early next year
okay so we have a
non-staffer Gambit D4 is one way to
prevent Stafford and it's just a
different line of the Petrov
um now there is Bishop C5
it depends how Brave I'm feeling let's
play Bishop C5
this is a line that um
there's actually like really really
crazy but
white kind of has to know what they're
doing
and the best move here isn't so simple
for lights
because I have two attackers against F2
and there's not too many like attractive
ways to defend
and it's a good sign that my opponent is
thinking here or not blitzing out the
next move
um I played this position actually from
both colors
and I will admit I've I've had games in
the past I've lost very quickly from the
black side of this position
I think the most recent game I had my
opponent played Bishop E3
which is basically the only way to not
lose off to
ooh
oh wow
there's a different way
Knight D4
uh this is a new move I will say the the
best move there was Bishop C4 it's like
the main main line
um there's a couple ideas that come to
mind here there's Knight F2 and queen H4
happy holidays oh yeah happy happy
holidays
tis the season
the move I want to play here is takes
takes Queen H4 the only thing I'm not
sure about is King E3
and then
white is holding on to the knights I
guess I keep calculating Knight C6 C3
and then something like Knight takes E5
and in that position I what's happening
I'll have one two pawns for the piece
the king's on E3 Knight's still pinned
I'll be ready to Castle play rookie
eight
let's do it
this reminds me of the fried liver
it's actually very similar to fried
liver
but I guess with a few differences
fried liver is usually an opening you
play as white where you go for like
early Knight G5 in combination with
Bishop C4 and then there's a famous trap
with Knight F7
um but this has very similar vibes
and if white doesn't take the Knight
I'll win the queen or The Rook
so
okay white is maybe feeling some fear
here
thank you neogen hawk pancake Kremlin
Lord hadam the first time Zub
yeah I think my goal is to play the
whole tournament
um
just over two and a half hours
I'm not sure how many games that will
translate to
but hopefully at least between five and
ten
oh
okay so white uh
maybe didn't want to expose the king
but I can I mean I could take the Rook I
could also take the Knight
I think I'll take the Rook
I could also Play No Queen each voice
and do much
yeah I want to keep the bishop on the
board
the bishop has potential the knight's
still at Target
Queen H4 is a threat here
which would be a triple attack
against the Pawn King and Knight
foreign
hey welcome back PT player
thing duster also welcome back
Rose and effect more intense than nerves
of Magnus effect Eric plays a single
move and the opponent resigns trembling
in fear that Rose and will unsheath and
unleash his duck slash Ultimate Weapon
warm greetings from Liverpool yeah
that's basically what happened last game
when I was too afraid to meet E4
iPhone's playing a few more moves this
game though
also warm greetings from St Louis
the weather in St Louis hasn't gotten
too cold yet it hasn't really snowed
it was in the 50s yesterday
a little bit rainy today okay oppon
wants to check Maybe
so
um
considering D5 but then on passant I'll
just Castle
[Music]
it's funny if takes takes resembles a
Stafford just with the pawn structure
the fact that Bishop's developed and I
already went for the night uh Knight G4
Knight F2
oh yeah 50 degrees Fahrenheit maybe I
should specify
not Celsius
I would be a little bit concerning
D5
hey thank you path Morris
appreciate the read
actually don't recognize that name
shout out to path
if you're just joining I'm streaming the
rapid Shield Arena
this is a more chill instructive chess
stream
and this is my second game
although it's my first real game
my previous game my opponent didn't show
up
um I've already Run The Rook
like trying to get compensation
white might be going for like Bishop D3
and
some King side attack
but everything should be covered here
oh path is in in third place oh wow
from Germany
now I saw some people saying hello from
Germany
welcome to detox
so I assume path was like streaming the
games then
okay Bishop two B5
I mean
there's a lot of approaches here
I think one approach is to try and
Target the pawn
aligning with the King maybe preparing
F6
foreign
is hanging I'm still considering F6 but
and this is also a move just going for
C2
I think I'll just play Bishop B6
a solid move
and no need to do anything too special
I'll bring the Knight back
and this also prevents light from
castling so
it's actually a nice configuration
Queen defends a
the bishop which defends the Knight
which prevents white from castling
okay so H6
I really wouldn't mind if that file
opens
and if I get the chance probably a move
like Knight T4 could be nice
killing the pawn the bishop
okay 13 move game
uh real quick I'll I'll analyze because
this opening was kind of uh
interesting Knight T4
a new game started
uh
okay hopefully find time to analyze
later
I mean if people want you can go to my
leechas profile and uh analyze on your
own with engine
so this game
uh we have a French
I've been playing a lot of orthostnop
recently
okay I was going for a two nights attack
um I have six is a little bit offbeat
it's kind of like combining a French and
alkyne
so I'm debating here whether it's uh
like to try and transpose into two
nights attack or punish this game let me
try and punish the move we'll play a
tournament with your merch on the 26th
of December Plaza wish me luck and keep
up the great content you are a great
inspiration
lavio corpora getting merch
oh that's awesome
yeah best wishes appreciate that
merch still is on sale through December
15th
we have a Black Friday coupon so there's
a holiday sale they have a Checkers mode
not sure how it works in terms of King
promotion also wanting to know how
promotion Works in regular chess would
getting extra pieces help make it easier
quack love
welcome back Amber
um I don't know if I can actually
address those questions
especially when it comes to Checkers
mode
um but the the child supports are also
in stock and make for a good gift we do
have the chess up command
but the Trestle boards do come with an
extra Queen so
um
that accounts for the majority of
promotion cases
and when you're playing with the app you
can you can select under promote in the
app as well
is moving very quickly here
hitting the Knight also hitting those
Pawn still
um I think this wins
this is Win material
so takes takes Knight C4 Queen E2
looks good to me
as my third game of this tournament but
longest game thus far only came to
surpass 14 moves
um yeah this is a calculation Queen E2
so I hit the Knight the bishop will
escape
and yeah I'm basically up the exchange
here
I don't have any dough merch or da but
maybe at some points
I think in 2023 I'll um very much
consider adding
new merch options new designs
okay so here I'm up a full Rook
uh Queen D2 was kind of a threat
now I'm hitting the each Pawn
five Bishop F3
yeah this is kind of a similar theme to
the previous game like I win material
early and then it's just about playing
normally
um
G3 actually just traps a queen
the funny Queen job E5 cut out the the
one Retreat that the queen had
and now Queen C4 and I'll pick up the
queen for free
I mean black did have Queen D2 to
lose a bishop instead of a full Queen
okay
pretty smooth game love you Eric
I love you too
yeah generally like when you play the
French you could you should almost
always follow up with D5
and I have six as we saw gets hit with
E5 and it's still playable it could have
resembled more of an alkyne
but um
anyway yeah that went
it turns out to be a very good position
very quickly
so that's three in a row
trying to break into the top thousand
welcome back I'm Kozak
hey it's Pam
says I'm almost back at my Peak rating
all because of my buddy Eric I don't
think I can take full credit
I mean
success in reading game it's it's
generally cons it's done generally
um
made up of like hard work and
persistence
okay so new opponent playing uh Babylon
I'll play Knight F6
been playing D5 more lately
um maybe I'll play like some nimzo
haven't played a ninja in a while
this is known as the Leningrad variation
okay so this is kind of a new position
for me like usually people play Bishop
H4
the first move that comes to mind is C5
just to pressure
mainly D4 and C3
some intention to play Knight C6 next
yeah E3 is a move
considering this
is not sure about 92.
like if I want to take this is my one
chance to take and force White's pawns
to double
I actually like that
it's a more positional approach and now
Knight C6
and I think the plan is to go for some
setup where most of my pawns go on dark
squares
because I
have the light squared Bishop
yeah very likely Castle
and now I could start with E5 I could
start with B6
but this is a very very typical ninja
structure
I think I'll start with B6
although B6 could walk into D5
foreign
repertoire
maybe E5
oh Paul carries
I'll admit I haven't studied his games
like so closely to know his
exact opening repertoire and some of our
openings may be overlap
I'm sure he's played the nimzoo at some
point
um
and this is like such a standard nimso
Indian position especially the structure
with double C Pawns
um and also potential
or some attack on the king side
so like even the light has more space in
the center
it's arguably a bit easier for black to
play
um now it's still a question how to
proceed with the plans here I think I'll
start with my G6
and I don't want to trade off lights for
Bishops
but if I play Bishop A6 there's Queen A4
Bishop G4 is a wise move
I'm actually considering Bishop B7
what's the bishop on um
of like bad Square basically but
it's just temporary
and the intentions to play Queen G5
pressure the bishop and the Knights
and then later either return to C8
or move up to A6
okay so there's a few questions to ask
first question is what does white want
to do so F4 is not really a threat
if I play this it does give white kind
of a free tempo
don't want to allow that
I'm realizing like maybe it does make
sense to play Bishop C8
also maybe makes sense to improve the
night
is now not doing so much
but it is preventing white from playing
F4
okay I have a plan
it's a little bit embarrassing but I'm
just gonna admit I
I went for the wrong idea
I don't think it's too costly
okay let's see with this Rook
my plan is to eventually play F5
but to achieve that takes a bit of work
I might play this move actually
offer the queen trade and fully restrict
F4
but I have to watch out for you know
Queen D7 I would be hitting the knights
okay so the game is taking a very um
very quiet approach
traded Bishops and queens
but at least now there's
there's some go-to plans I can uh
I can go for
like one plans to maneuver the Knight to
A5
pressure the C pong
but it's kind of like a maze like to get
to A5 I need to go from I'm kind of
working my way backwards so it's
probably this maneuver
uh so this path takes a lot of moves
I'm considering
five is maybe two weakening so maybe
something like F6
to start with
enabling this but also enabling the
Knight to travel
A5 is a very good move
because I don't want to play A5 myself I
also don't want to allow
white to play A5 I might have to
this isn't so simple
also spending a lot of time
and King should probably like come and
help out
and go for this
I mean
if necessary I'll have enough Defenders
I'm keeping the option open of playing
B5 later
Boyd's playing this very well I'm
playing quickly too
foreign
[Music]
yeah like the knights maybe I'll start
with this
point pre-moving
I mean White's definitely trying to
pressure me on the clock
okay now the King has time to run
foreign
gets to A4
how does my knight get to C7
E8
there's really no way to get to C7
like a weird maze
okay my king got to see Saturn
I have G4
okay this is some opportunity
like if I just made some unnecessary
weakness
and now oh now I can start munching
this night is hungry
Knight C3 will Fork the rook and the
e-pawn
don't think the knight's getting trapped
unless it is
which would be really sad but at the
very least I have had five minus six
which I might have to go for
oh wow may I have this move
okay I just won three Pawns
the funny uh hello Eric You Beautiful
human smile
oh hello you beautiful black goose
and just start pushing
I could also defend
how to do this
[Music]
maybe it's worth defending first
hi Eric happy holidays to you and yours
and chapter and toggy
oh thank you vector
oh thank you anniversary
okay let's play this move
it's still a very confusing position
like despite being up three Pawns
I like my chances though
there's a funny line like each six
Knight F4 can use seven G5 check
and then King h8 and it's so close to
mate
I'm gonna win this Pawn
maybe this first
but not necessary though
I feel so cramped
I'm essentially sagging a pond uh
breathe a little bit easier
now I was up for Pawn so sagging upon
wasn't the biggest price to pay
okay
I could start with the G6
considering some Rook move
oh it's so close
let's move back
okay at this point it's it's mainly
about end game technique
it's weird that I'm a three pawns and
I'm still like really passive
but I'm I'm just trying to not lose B6
at some point maybe I should go for a B5
[Music]
okay B5 achieved
foreign
plenty of time here
the king will come around
it's nice having a sleep on
I'll probably just come around and win
the
white slash Pawn
thank you aruma
subbing for the first time
yeah this is a pretty standard end game
to win
the strategy is to gradually Advance the
Pawns
um there's actually some funny potential
checkmates
maybe I'll try and go for
like one potential mating idea is to
play G5 with a rook on A3
so I'm gonna try and set that up you
have King F4 G5
hey G5 checkmate
I think I got two rows and jerseys for
that
because there's a pawn Checkmate the G5
is a special
emote Worthy checkmates
64 moves that was my longest game thus
far
um
can't say I'm so proud of this game
I mean we got like a typical nimso
position
I think I mishandled things a little bit
like maybe I should have gone for
like some quicker F5
white played though played pretty well
though to resist
and this plan was very nice
I think once white Optimizer Rooks then
H4 was a little bit self-destructive
and then of course taking with Pawn
should have taken with Knight
okay back to tournaments yeah it's
possible that I could have chosen a
different route for the night in the
opening
1995 is
sometimes a bit more strategic thanks to
everyone for being here
appreciate those who've subbed sorry if
I didn't address everyone
we had uh Jay Robinson 3k1 something
with probably for the first time
playing little green dragon
uh berserking this game
and we have maybe I'll play
I play into a Carroll Khan
let's do it
opponent wants a Carol Khan
man I haven't played this line in a
while
I'll go for
um a slightly unusual line Knight H3
idea Knight F4
M Rosen angry Goose him Rose an angry
goose in Rose and angry goose
oh don't be angry
even if you're a goose
also thank you OG Marco
Dad this is a line I learned when I was
a small child
actually I learned a 92 not F4 but okay
the lines kind of transpose
with the 99 F4 it creates some ideas of
an H5
um I think I'll start with Bishop D2
no black I don't think black is from the
E5
is E5 I think creates too many issues
with the King
Queen side Castle
I think black is playing this very fine
for the rating
E6 probably coming
there's an idea I want to set up just
not sure how to set it up
maybe I'll just start with Queen A3
but that allows E5
so maybe I'll start with this move
threatening F7
and my queen wants to be on A4
for a few reasons one is just purely
positional is to
um exert constant pressure
and it's a hard place for
the queen to actually be attacked
Knight B6 and Knight C5 are not playable
[Music]
now I'm just realizing the second reason
for Queen A4
doesn't actually work right away
of
I have Knight H5
let's play this
foreign
I'll go ahead and say like the the other
reason is to prepare Bishop A5
which I really want to play here but
then there's Queen A6 pinning the bishop
but a different idea
different idea also doesn't work I want
to play this move but then Queen D4
wow
maybe I'll play this move
is migrating
to the West
Knights want to do damage against the
black king
threatening the undefended bishop
I mean eventually I do want to go for
this
but
it's frustrating it doesn't work
like the queen either needs to be
defended
or I would need some Knight C5
I want to play C4 too but D4 still hangs
very frustrating position
thinking of crazy idea Rook H3
like later possibility is a rook B3
that's like one of the side effects with
H4 it wasn't the original plan
F5
so if I play Knight C5 takes takes takes
F5 looks like a fine move
I don't think Knight C5 works
I mean do I have this and then Knight C5
takes takes
I lose a piece in the end though
not the move I wanted to play
I think things are still under control
[Music]
G5
okay might as well take
[Music]
it doesn't work though
or does it maybe it does
allowing takes takes takes but then
Bishop E3
guaranteeing to win a seven
this might not work though
it gets crazy
and queen F2 is like really risky
that's so frustrating Bishop 85.86
still
I'd like to set up some
some trick
well now okay now it actually
looks feasible
because A6 prevented Queen A6
and there is Queen F2
but this should be good for white
opponently is a very good Carroll Khan
other bullet ratings a bit higher okay
okay now I just have to speed things up
uh if I take
King B1
F4 coming
here we go
box holding on to the pawn
maybe this move
going for A4
okay never mind I returned
each five should be a goner
Rook G8 was playable
oh thank you Orizon Missouri
oh it's so close to meat
I'm I'm gonna win another Pawn here
oh no my Pawn
okay
non-easy game
Napoleon definitely like play the
opening much higher than their rating
um
but I guess that's one of the features
of Carol Khan like it's
it just requires a lot of simple moves
I think black did all the things that
you normally do in Cairo Khan and then
I wasn't able to like easily crack the
position
[Music]
and I kept wanting to like do tricks but
couldn't quite make things work
still got the job done
moving up in the world
top 550
hello to Irene
yeah again if you're just joining we
have less than two hours left of the
rapid Shield Arena
um
I don't think I'll get the shield the
winner of this tournament gets like a
shield trophy
until the next Arena next month
I'm very far away from first place
we see the previous Shield winner here
doesn't look like they'll defend their
Shield
okay oh playing a stronger opponent
stronger than the previous games
I'll hold off from berserking
I'll play a
maybe I'll mix up the opening maybe I'll
play like a classical Sicilian
or white will mix up the opening
and now I have to remember what I play
against her Russo limo
um I'll play E6
generally my structure of choice
yeah this is some line that I haven't
looked at in a long time
I'll admit I don't think I've ever like
seriously studied
this line in depth I just know that this
is a move and then
like either F6 or Knight G6
being a G6 first
sometimes lock will go for E5 hi Eric
haven't been able to catch you live for
a while good to see you again oh yeah
it's good to live thank you honu kicks
and there's D5 here too but
D5 is sometimes a little bit committal
I'm trying to understand like if F6 E5
I think that's okay
it's so weird like it seems very
anti-positional
the idea is to undermine the
I mean White's only Bishop on the board
um generally when white trades off a
bishop early then you want to put your
pawns on the same color as the remaining
Bishop just to restrict it
uh so we might see E5
we see C4 okay so that allows me to play
E5
which I think I'm content with
now there's a simple path to development
the center is staying closed
I'll play D6 first don't think there's a
huge difference maybe bishop E7 first
I think um going forward in the middle
game the plans to eventually play F5
and open up some
possibilities for the Bishops
but yeah this is a very nice structure
against
the fiend-colored bishop
now there's also an idea of Knight F4
and bring the queen in
but white can easily
diffuse things with the Knight
so let's start slow
and simple
I do have this move too
[Music]
which reminds me of one of the previous
games I played my opponent did to me
against this like almost exact same
structure but reverse
is I create a situation where
I'll either get an A4
do I even want to play A4 takes
I'm gonna say either I get an A4 or
white plays A4 and weakens B3
but maybe I play on this side now like
F5
and there's Queen side potential then
I'm not going to commit
one strategy is to try and spread white
thin
like peanut butter
playing on both sides of the board
pairing my butter knife
yeah this is actually a like pretty
annoying pin for white to deal with an
H4
now there's three attackers
there are three Defenders
but very soon I'll like I'll damage the
structure
and I can choose whether to take with
Knight or Bishop
or maybe just build up more tension like
rocast 7 queen of fate
oh yeah I could turn on my heart rate
monitor except where's my watch
why is my watch in my pocket
okay it's still alive
foreign
there's some viewers that have gotten so
used to me having the heart rate monitor
maybe feels weird when I don't have it
Okay so
yeah I'm thinking Queen E8
the Queenie queen of seven
and taking is possible that
just doesn't seem necessary
there's also some crazy like Rook F4
or Rook F7
I do like the prospect of the queen
being behind The Rook
yeah let me let me go for Augustana
foreign
faced
yeah so white wants to play Knight D2
adding a fourth Defender to the pin
Knight
I really want to go crazy here
but I should also stay controlled
like now is probably the time to take
there's also Bishop G5 which
I think
like there's a G5 Knight G5 Bishop E2
Knight F7
when some material
I could also take first and then Bishop
G5
rookie four I take
there's so many ways to just win
material
I like this option though
I'm cashing in
darks for Bishop has finally come to
life
and black or white will either have to
give away the Rook or lose upon
a rookie for his only way to save The
Rook
92 instead
okay I'll take
and Rook F7 still turned out to be a
useful move because
I can double up in a single move
Queen H5 also coming
now there's four attackers I mean F3 is
still a focal point
it's still pinned too
like rather than like being pinned it's
upon being pinned
okay
yeah up material
White's position is gradually crumbling
we might see this move my knight is
pinned to the queen
oh
I really want to go crazy here so I
can't take the Rook
or can I
no I can't take the Rook
can I Target H2 like this and this
94
yeah maybe this is the way to go like
Rook off six and then
just uh lift The Rook over to H6
still takes a bit of effort
any weights trying to money the waters
I could take first
so what if I play this
and there's Rook G2
but then I take on D2
take
foreign
it gets so close but
still a little bit confusing I could
also just take twice
Bishop takes and then up and then yeah
it's weird
okay
I'm looking for the easy put away
I'm not fully seeing it Rook H6 Knight
take
Rook take Pawn take Pawn take
and then Rook G6 how about so I undouble
the Pawns
there are a lot of options to choose
from
I like this option because it um it just
aims to simplify
and it also diffuses uh
crash dragons G7
also friends made in one
so if after it takes takes
takes
I just take back
Knight takes I take with Rook I'll be
threatening the bishop
and now it's important to note my
Queen's defended so the knights no
longer actually pinned
so like this is already
a possibility
like actually if takes I I take here
then we trade
yeah maybe I wouldn't take
like I probably want to leave Queens on
the board because White's King is
far less safe than my king
so I should only trade Queens if it
leads to
some easy to win position
really tempted to play this move
I think I'll play this
offering the queen trade
and the cool thing
oh it's defending
oh where's my funny tactic
maybe this move
yeah fun fact if um
if Queen takes Queen I would not have
taken back I would have played Rook F1
checkmate
so one of the goals is to drive the
queen away from covering F1
in this position I'm threatening made in
two
with Queen F1
or even more beautiful queen E4 oh no my
queen and then mate
and I don't see I don't see how white
survives
actually maybe there's one move to try
and survive
I only see one attempt for white here
oh I was thinking H3
that's a move
is it
I mean D5 there should be a lot of ways
to win
I gotta watch my time
I like D5
let's remove the knights because I want
to go into F2
foreign
yeah this plan of F6 and E5 like even
though it disobeyed a lot of opening
principles like moving the F Pawn not
developing the pieces
I think it was justified like
positionally it just made things a lot
easier to play reduce whites attempt to
open the center and then yeah once I got
an F5 things were pretty
blowing
especially once I got the PIN
okay gain some rating
back to tournament
420 with 21 points
pretty nice
OG cocoa to finish the game with Queen
F1
yeah Queen F1
maybe a slightly cooler finish
but would have been slightly less
efficient
a lot of mating ideas towards the end
there
so maybe it could be possible to finish
in the top hundred
top 10 is 73 points which
probably not reaching
I'm not gonna berserk
I'll just play
maybe I'll try and mix up the openings
more
and get some variety
um
I'll play a scandi
can play one of these
okay this is already known to be
like not great for for whites
because the trade just gives me a nice
Center
I'll play Knight C6 and go for E5
thank you Greg Lee Gregory Beijing
gifting two
I'm really tempted to play this
wasn't there some like Magnus Carlsen
Bill Gates game that went something like
this
I love you posted a video earlier
but like Queen H5 it's uh it's more
relying on some hope chests like hoping
like goes wrong
I think Bishop H5 is
just as suitable
not taking any risks
I do want to go for E5 and castling
yeah there were better ways to handle
this opening
like as white like
Knight C3 is a playable move usually
like Bishop C4 and queen F3 would be the
the follow-up
okay so I'm considering E5 or casting
I think I'll play E5
who controls the center
the only way to attack the queen is C4
but that's
a bit committal as it would weaken uh
the d-pawn weaken the D4 Square
foreign
just passive but aims complete
development
I mean my plan is a castle and probably
go for some quick expansion
get the bishop into play
oh Knight H2
so offering the trade
I have a choice here I could take and
then maybe go for Knight D4
hitting
hitting the C Pawn
I could also just play this move
leave white and a little bit cramped
both options look appealing
probably not worth spending like too
much time
I think I'll just go for this
I mean Bishop 3 is met with E4
there is a line though Bishop 3 E4
rookie one but then like Castle
so I guess there's D3
I'm still ready to Castle
[Music]
let me calculate D3 Castle Bishop F3 E4
take take
So eventually the bishop will land on D1
like let's say take take take
I take
probably slightly better for black
I mean maybe better after casting Bishop
F3 I'd play something like Queen D6
and then preparing that D4
I can play Knight D4 immediately too
let's start with castling
making the game Sharp
so now that the kings are on opposite
sides
it is a matter of trying to accelerate
the attack quicker than white
and that's easier to do when I have more
Center control and more space
yeah Magnus has played the Scandia
handful of times over the years
now I think this game against Bill Gates
was maybe one one of the most viewed
chess videos on YouTube
he won in something like 12 moves
but he's played the scandi I mean I
featured like a brilliant game of his
recent YouTube video
[Music]
where he uh played a really cool Gambit
line
completely dismantled uh decently strong
GM
okay here I'll go for F5
creating
upon possibilities
and white very quickly responds with F4
debating between taking and Bishop C5
my knight wants to travel to G3
actually Bishop T5 looks nice
because after it takes takes King H1 I
have E4 and then there's a pin
and just controlling more space
yeah Magnus is pretty much played every
oh we can a handful of times
it's actually a really cool part about
his style that he's
he's silver style in the openings
and I'll just like make things up and
get away with it
yeah not only does this move pressure
the pin Pawn but it restricts the minor
pieces it takes away the F3 Square
which is like the main developing Square
for both the Knight and the bishop
so even though I haven't won any
material yet
there's a lot of just nice advantages in
this position for lack
I'm still dreaming of Knight G3
checkmates
but to get there
it would be a long journey
I would need to
have access to F5 or E2
B4 may be coming
if I'm attacking C2
and one idea with this move is if I play
C3 I
it feels wrong taking the bishop
but I would win the d-pawn
so it defends
but C3 is still not a concern I'll just
centralize a rook
and now I'm threatening to take and then
take and
the center would crumble for white
there's a funny line where I take on D3
Bishop D3 and then Knight E2
capitalizing on the pin but also
threatening the rook and also
threatening mate
so that would be
that would be a really cool example of a
pork
because it's a pin and a fork
and 92 unleashes the pin it's like a
discovered
pin
so discovered pork
oh it's a disco pork
if you Google disco pork
you might find uh
a funny thumbnail
or you just might find some Mexican
style pork dishes
hmm
[Music]
so B4
yeah I want to keep the queen on the
diagonal but Queen C3 is also
really attractive
like Queen C3 Queen E1
world of Queen B6 though let's just play
Queen B6
essentially the same situation
I'm actually really disappointed
like my thumbnail doesn't appear
disco pork chess
there we go okay yeah this is the
thumbnail that I made
uh over a year ago
okay
so if I play this move
or this move
let's play this move
both files open bishop and queen are
both targets
and this move is still an idea
and Knight E2
I think I still it's I still get away
with it it's a disco pork
discovered pork
it's a discovery because I unleash the
Rook
it's a pin because The Bishop's pinned
and it's a fork because I'm threatening
this and this
and this would be a Checkmate Fork
a chork
wow
did why you really just defend
I mean I could take I could take but
then take
yeah White's coming out alive
but I should win a pawn at the end of
this
all that work for winning upon
opponent's still taking time though oh
there's a cool move actually
if takes I I might
I might sack my Rook
I'll actually share it so uh after it
takes I'm looking at Queen E3 takes on
the Knight G3 take take
but there'd be yeah I'd give away the
two Rooks for the queen
at least in this line I'm winning the
rook and then winning the pawn
opponent left the game
pawns back
okay
maybe some internet issues
oh yeah internet issues
I'm keeping the time advantage
threatening the
the disco disco Fork
yeah discovered Fork
ooh
that's a move
can I play this move
there's a really beautiful ending I kind
of want to try and achieve
play this move
hopefully this doesn't backfire
I'm taking some risk here though
so the funny line is after it takes
takes
threading The Rook
so I'm threatening The Rook I'm
threatening Knight G3 but I I have an
even deadlier threat like if it's my
move I don't play this and I don't play
this
okay I might defend it against it oh no
I didn't defend against it
okay
yeah I've been threatening Maiden two
with Queen G1
I was kind of hoping
this would play out positions already
completely winning
but this would have been a cool finish
like it's pretty rare that you see
smothered mates
with a knight coming to G3
combined with the queen sack usually
then that comes F2
but uh okay white uh
a lot of Queen G1
G4 was uh was maybe playable
I wasn't sure what I was going to do
against G4 but maybe just Bishop back
and then
this is hard to stop
a lot of winning moves
okay that was a fun game
um wait was I worse at some point
White's apparently doing okay after C4
then
things were oh things were not under
control
so White's okay here
after CD3
no it's still better for black but
maybe it's not so simple
ah White had Rook C5 wow
which almost equalizes
anyway okay back to tournaments
one hour 23 minutes left
329
some fun tactics in that game
I'll still try and keep mixing up the
openings
also trying to chase 2600 rapid
I've been close recently and then I like
I get close I lose the game and fall
back down
what's that song about like falling down
and then getting up again
like vaguely remembering the beat
something about
but I get up again
Chumbawamba oh yeah Chumbawamba I would
play the music now but it's probably
copyrighted oh no my opponent
wow so the first game of the stream I
played E4 and my opponent
uh basically just forfeited but this
game I didn't even have to play E4
I would say GG but that was like a
non-game
okay playing velazano
not berserking
um not Biz Ricky because I don't really
have intentions to try and win the
tournament I just want to have time to
explain the ideas behind my moves
try and provide some instructional
commentary
so here we have a Budapest Gambit
it's one of my favorite opening slash
gambits
I've been playing this for many years
now this is one of the
uh popular lines at White House against
Budapest
the benefit here for black is I'm
controlling this diagonal and if white
wants to Castle
it takes some work to get rid of this
bishop
I'm gonna just Castle here
I mean the downside of this position for
black is
like the queen side development's a
little bit awkward
because this nylon C6 is usually
on F6 and the other night goes to C6
but um
yeah there's workarounds
so one idea is Bishop G4 and Knight D7
White's going for this move which
makes sense
I think I'll still play Bishop G4
some idea Knight D4 and then
I can develop the other Knight to C6
foreign
use of the PIN
I wouldn't mind if I got the bishop hair
although if I do get the best repair oh
what does this move
I was gonna say what would maybe have
each three in some lines
it's a free Queen
it took me a moment to spot
I was calculating takes takes takes
Bishop H3
it was one of those things like
opponent gave me a present and I wasn't
expecting a present I I didn't know to
look under the Christmas tree
I always have to keep the eyes open
okay
I was even considering like Knight C6 I
reinforce uh the PIN
yeah white should have um should have
taken
maybe Queen F2 is playable
take take in this line the bishop
maintains its uh dominance
a wooden Shield
okay that was a quick game
top 200.
another few quick games there
oops my longest game was um
the game against Babylon
nimso game
okay playing valence
I'll mix it up
I played E4 already and I played D4
already so let's play C4
and go for an English opening
there's usually some percentage of
English players in chat
players who play the English or maybe
are from England
um this aims to transpose into a blob
like if I play D4
but I'll play E3
and okay this is now semi-slav formation
like maybe I'll play D4 but maybe I'll
play B3
mixing things up a little bit
uh Magnus Carlson played a very similar
opening against me recently
where he just Uncorked G4
which I'm really tempted to do in this
position
like G4 takes and then Rook G1
yeah let me try and play like magnets
the position we had my Pawn was still on
I think my Pawn was on
C7 my Bishop was back
it was similar though
I'm pretty sure it's safe to say I've
never played this before as white
um but the idea is just to play G5 and
get some early attack
because I'm I'm gonna think out of the
bishop on B2
each Pawn can follow
um
I wonder if I should have played Rook G1
first
because the pawn is attacked here and if
I take I I still lose the pawn because
Knight has to move
I'm debating between Rook G1 and H4
I'll play H4
because there's cases where the Rook
might just want to stay on each one
and now if takes I'll take with the pawn
it's possible the bishop won't be encato
if I have a pawn C3
okay here
I mean Bishop B2
still looks nice
wow
I don't think it worked but black did
have an idea of Bishop G3
I wouldn't maybe I would be able to take
I don't know man this position is
getting spicy
so Queen C2
let's just play Queen C2
at some point I'll probably Castle
queenside
ideally I'd like to get in like H5 G6
Bishop G3 Bishop G3
the Bishops combined with a pawn storm
combined with the Rooks
that's a move
and this Knight's not defended so I
don't have too many options here
I could take
or I can play Bishop E2
let me take and then D4
thank you Crow tweets it's a first time
chat 100 bits
says greetings from Croatia
at greetings from St Louis
it's 4 46 p.m so
I think it's still a reasonably European
friendly time
good to see some Europeans in chat
also some non-europeans
welcome back Z Nation
I think this move just gives me a pawn
oh did Black have an alternative
I was more expecting takes but maybe I
could take back
yeah perhaps it was already difficult
but now this is really nice
because Bishop D3 will come
[Music]
oh I am losing castling rights
oh no my causing rights
but the king is still very safe behind
the wall of Center ponds
yeah Bishop D3
tanks for your stream smiley face smiley
face oh thank you
Allah Fletcher
yeah so the bishop combined with the
Rook
it's a nice combo
still a question
you just want to take and Sack a queen
but that would be irresponsible
maybe I could take on passant and then
take
I could start with F4
hello from Berlin also already one year
also quack
hey welcome back to Lumi happy one year
I've never been to Berlin but that's
one of the top
places in Germany I've never been to
before that I want to go to
I like F4
a simple solid
I mean there's constant pressure here
I probably could have just gone away
with taking
okay here I'll still take
I also probably could have gone away
with this
but then yeah that D5 wouldn't be
necessary right away
so where's the win
hey Rook H6
and G6 is one of the main targets here
I mean I'm always considering D5 the
problem is black takes hits a queen and
I can't actually win the bishop or win
uh The Rook with the bishop in a single
move
like I want to combine tactics where I
access h8
but this is a very simple low-risk move
also have some idea Queen age of one
trial battery
how fancy do I want to be let's be fancy
foreign
I have one Connect Four
I might be threatening Force mates
that is basically a dream come true
version of like what I wanted from this
opening
like when I play G4 on move six like
everything
like all the
ideas I wanted to achieve basically
happened
with uh the pawn storm
now the The Bishop's opening up
combined with each file
oh no my queen
someone call an ambulance
yeah because of rookies on F7 it takes
away the flight swear from the King
so if takes it would have been mate
um
Queen's not taken but
yeah I made is
coming pretty soon
now the king is still very safe on D1
okay there's one possible Spike Chuck
yeah I wanted to do a similar like D5
idea in previous positions but
it wouldn't work in the same way
realizing
yeah if King G and I play Rook h a king
E8
and Bishop G6 would be mate
okay let's game
a nice way of using an opening that I
got crushed against recently against
Magnus
using it in a game where I'm playing the
white side
so back to tournaments
top 150
hour and seven minutes left
I'm sure there are other
attacking ideas that probably would have
worked towards the end there
it was a very rich position
so I do want to keep like mixing up
openings
and maybe try and play things I haven't
played before
yeah welcome to all the people who are
new
I know a lot of people coming over from
YouTube
um
new opponents playing Iris star shows
so what other first moves can I play
Let's Play Knight of three
playing a righty
now the thing about the ready it can
transpose into other openings
but
there are certain lines that are unique
like for example this is now
Essentia reverse benoni
and
I mean do I know what I'm doing here I
think E3 is a move
C5 B4
yeah this is off online this is
basically a reverse blue invalid
where
okay maybe I'm not even sacking a pawn
but maybe I am
a block wants to win a pawn there's
takes takes takes
I play A3
oh
black One Connect Four
I'm pretty sure there's a tactic here
like a really funny tactical idea Knight
D4
and this is an opening trap I don't
think I've ever had because I don't
usually play this opening
but
I'm winning material because the Rook is
trapped
uh like probably probably best for luck
to get back the piece
but I'll still be up upon
the QT games
wow so I could take the Rook
we have to be careful that black doesn't
hit me with the same thing
but even if that happens
it should still be okay
like I could even take wait I have to I
mean
focus a little bit here
so it takes Queen D4 King E1 takes takes
takes mate
that could be a funny line
if I play this there's Bishop G4 King C2
I mean I'm up the exchange
basically upper Rook for 19 Pawn
in Bishop F5 I have D3
I mean generally Knight F3 and C4 leads
uh way more positional games
but we still see that even in
openings that have a more positional
reputation
there's still craziness that can ensue
yeah now it's just about
just getting my queen back into play
ensuring my king is not too naked
oh there's a funny trap here
we'll see if black Falls for it oh no my
Pawn
oh Black's actually winning the pawn or
no
it's black
I have this move
wait I have to be really careful
because my Queen's attacked
I'll start with Queen A4
so okay the the idea was after Vision
before I play Queen A4
uh winning the winning some minor piece
here I'm winning this Knight
yeah black should have played Queen D7
or Bishop D7
too many free presents
wait there's before
not a big concern
sometimes the first thing to address
when you're in a winning position is
what the opponent's ideas are
because it can be so easy to get
careless
but generally when you're winning it's
just about preventing counter play
and not plundering
1095
Z Nation asking do title players use
chaspable much
I'm probably not the best person to ask
regarding that
if I had to guess
when we're speaking of title players I
assume like FM and higher
I'd imagine only a very small percentage
too
[Music]
um
especially when you compare it to
something like chess base
which probably every title player uses
I guess these days
you can substitute chess base for
something like the chest study but
chess base is still probably the
overwhelmingly like most used software
among title players
and myself included like I
I think I've purchased one shotsball
course but never actually really used it
like I purchased it trying to download
it like download the PG and into chess
space and I realized that's not possible
um so
what to do
but I prefer using like chess base or
the chat study when it comes to
like reviewing analyzing
and creating like opening repertoires
have you used chassify I have I think we
still have the Justified command
I haven't used justify so much
it's a very Niche product but if you're
like a
because it does have its target audience
mainly for like strong title players
that want to do more in-depth opening
work
um gives you access to Cloud engines
like very powerful Cloud engines
uh Queen H4 I really wanted to take but
the problem is Bishop takes
I still have to be a little bit careful
here
a nice thing about this move I'm hitting
this and this preparing this to hit each
seven
thank you pitch bucket
oh there's a question which course I
assume which course I bought I got one
of Sam shanklin's D4
repertoire courses I got it very
specifically because I knew one of my
opponents in a recent tournament
uh had like learned from that course I
wanted to see what he recommended
against a certain line
um
and I the the course itself I think it
was like very thoroughly prepared
I think Sam Sam in general does a great
job like being super thorough with
opening prop
but I was hoping I'd be able to review
it in chess space
yeah I still want to put the
this collab with lafong on YouTube
have to get around to editing that
was a collaboration we did recently
where
we played against each other but we
played in like we played from bot
accounts where we could use whatever
engine help that we wanted
and it led to some really fascinating
games
okay
got the job done there that took a
little bit of just patience towards the
end
um that was a cool trap though
like Glock played what looks like a
normal move to try and keep the pawns
together
but it was just a bit too weakening
that's a common theme in some of these
openings uh that this diagonal gets
exploited
I'm just curious how many people in the
past have fallen for this
if I had to guess it's probably like
1500 to 2000 I assume this is a common
trap
We Trust database
872 but this position has been reached
over 10 000 times
oh wow the best move is not even Knight
T4
best move is 95.
Bishop B7 Queen A4 how does this line go
so it takes
uh this is some Engine line it's a cool
idea though to play C5 and
C6 is now a threat
I mean Knight D4 just seemed like a
clean way to win the pawn
okay a fun opening
thank you munchie 400 happy 16 months
that's the type of trap maybe you you
fall for once and then you learn your
lesson
um but those can be tricky positions to
play for Block
oh this is a point where I I won that
nice game with this uh early G4 move in
the opening
so we play again
asking verpanziani
maybe later if I'm white I'll play E4
I mean I've really been trying to mix up
the openings
uh here we have an alapin
honestly I don't have too many different
options I can play against alapan I
usually play D5
I kind of want to mix things up
like G6 is a move
I have six is a move maybe I'll play
Knight of six
like the two main moves are Knight F6
and D5 D6 and G6 are also lines
Queen A5 is even a line
I'm just trying to get something fresh
I have some vague memory of studying G6
Bishop G7
not sure it was here or later
I know these lines can be tricky though
let me play G6
I'm completely out of prep and like kind
of a popular opening
but the idea is to play Bishop G7 in
Castle D6 Target the pawn
and taking looks normal
taking maybe a lot of Queen takes
foreign
have to be careful here
if Queen takes
I see seven E6 F6
looks really ugly
I don't see anything wrong with it
though
concerning D6 as well
foreign
I feel like I've I've already gone wrong
in some way
um I just want to get out of the opening
alive
I think Bishop G7 is most flexible
we'll see what white is up to
I remember looking at similar lines like
a long time ago specifically the
structure
when the bishop is aimed against these
Pawns
the eventual idea of D6 Knight C6 Bishop
G4 it's a way of exerting a lot of
pressure
on white I think I have to play Knight
P6 here
it might be six is nice because it it
saves the Knight and hits a bishop
Bishop moves like Castle
and now D6 is a next intention
H3 okay
it seems like white has some experience
playing H3 very quickly but I'll
continue adding pressure
I mean the goal is to induce taking and
after Queen takes there's three
attackers against iqp
so Bishop F4
this defends E5
yeah white actually has a lot of ways to
reinforce E5
there's a question how my Bishop can
play a role in the position of course I
have Bishop
F5
but maybe what I would consider is
Bishop
I was thinking some combination of
Bishop F5 Knight A5
if I take take
Queen C7
rookie one
taken trade Queens
I'm also wondering about some idea like
Bishop F5 with the attention of Bishop
E4
just to remove the Knight
problem is white has very simple
Knight C3
but then maybe Knight A5
I think I'll just start with Bishop F5
because I also have to be aware white
might just want to take
I mean there's idea of take take Bishop
F5
and use the D3 Square
again Knight C3
I see three Knight B4
it's gonna get sharp I think regardless
the first the first question is if I
want to allow taking
I think it's okay to allow
because after it take stakes and the
bishop has more scope
and we both would have isolate Pawns
so Knight C3 okay so now
I shouldn't be taking too much time here
but Knight F5 looks like a fine option
let's have some grunfeld ideas to it
I think it's it's common the green
palette to play a movie like 95.
exploit the C4 Square
so this Knight's pinned
some idea Knight D5
yeah there's a lot of similarities with
green Fallon grunfels not an opening I
play but
I'm aware of the principles of it where
you usually give white a big Center and
then you
uh you very much go for counter punching
like Knight C4
Queen C1
okay let's go for an ic4
comes with tempo
okay what can be improved maybe the
queen maybe just Queen D7
and give the Rook some options
some idea Queen F5
I didn't really want to release
attention because that would give white
the D file
like I want to leave the pawn in D4
because it's
it could be an eventual Target
I'm not really scared of B3 here either
okay baby I'm now I'm a bit more scared
the knights defended
I do have queen of five
very strategic game so far
hitting the bishop activating so now I
have four attackers there's still four
Defenders
expecting this or that
I could play Rook d8
the B3 comes I'm gonna have to
until I finally give an intake Knight H4
is not a concern okay let's play Rook d8
yeah so B3 it would Chase my knight away
but it's still weak in C3 a bit
so it's like a middle move like once we
go for it I'm also realizing maybe I
should have considered that last move is
this idea Bishop H6
just a different diagonal for the bishop
you probably wouldn't do much
but I should be aware of the resource
another idea with Rook da is to take
take Queen D3
trade Queens
yeah very soon Bishop H6 could become
more relevant
because the Rook is the only defender of
the knights
this Knight probably wants to return to
C6
one move I haven't considered that maybe
I should at least have on my radar is D5
just to completely close things down
and then the play would shift to the
flanks
I think one problem could be Queen B5
my queen B5 Knight C6 and the tensions
remain for so long like
ever since white or ever since I played
D6
so much tension
but it's just it's a situation where I
think when white takes it favors me
just as I say that
uh White does take
now I guess we'll see
okay so we both have iqps
as a different iqp situation because we
we can't attack 0.25 babies
hey that's um
is that a healthy number of babies
welcome back evanism
okay Bishop H6 forces Rooks T2
and then Knight C6 oh it's so close
maybe Knight C6 first
there's rookie eight as well
at Bishop H6 Rook C2 rookie 8.
that win
man that's so close to winning let's um
let's play it
it's crazy of this like if this is
winning
it was kind of a tactic out of nowhere
but
the fact that the Rook is tied down to
the Knight rookie it's a queen Queen's
tied down now to defending the Rook
and there's really not too many options
like 94 I just take it Queen D3 is
really the only option
now I was thinking Knight D5 but
I really want to play rookie one but 91.
yeah maybe it's not quite winning like
the intention
was take take Knight D5 but then after
it takes takes
net F6 King f898
maybe even losing D6 in the end it still
looks good though like
how do I
I can't spend too much time either
maybe I just take and
taken D5
so this prevents me from playing Knight
D5 but it does
uh
save the pawn because Bishop D6 was kind
of a threat
so if I'd taken Rook C2
I think I'm winning a pawn
there's Knight C3
looks very shaky for white though
I mean Knight C3 holds
holds A2
maybe I would play this
Knight C6 Knight B4
foreign
space
and close to a bullet game for me
but the position size okay I got what I
kind of wanted out of the middle game
like I haven't won material yet but I'm
very close to any material
it's actually nice that this Pond is
fixed on a dark Square
just given the bishop situation
don't think I need to take that
might see rookie three
a knight really doesn't oh the Knight
has D3
but I'm officially up a pawn
foreign
[Music]
makes sense to take
got my two horses
there's F6
is Rook Rook B2 first
I just want to win more Pawns
like B3 and D4 are targets
taking on D4 seems a little bit risky
but
is there anything wrong with it
Rook c792.
I want to play Rook C2 which would
nearly force a rook trade
and this is a clear threat
This Night play is a really important
role in defending c8s
okay five maybe just A6
out of them Bishop E3
so maybe I go for something like this
or F6
I like the prospect of F6 just chasing
another way
really
okay all about simplifying and moving
quickly and pushing Pawns
maybe making Queens
a long game
foreign
Knight B3
the knights work together and like
dominating the bishop
controlling a lot of dark squares
ooh but not F6
let's play D4
I have two pass Pawns
foreign
oops
what did I do
not see the night could move in an L
shape
okay I'll learn from my past mistakes
and not play A2
it's a good thing about being up
a few pawns when I lose a pawn I'm still
at Pawns
okay
that's like work all that work for one
rating points
but yeah instructive game
a very tense middle game
got some nice grunefeld type ideas
improve the pieces
took a while to win material
yeah this bishop H6 was nice
I'm actually curious if I had any better
options here
instead of D5
engine likes D5 engine actually says
whites better wow
but yeah I think it's easier to play for
black
Bishop D6 is a hard boot to find
foreign
33 minutes left
yeah this is my resting heart rate
not quite my sleeping heart rate I think
sleeping heart rate is more
maybe in the 50s
have I passed 100 in the Stream
I feel like I probably have at some
point
so I did mention earlier if I got the
chances white to play ponziani
I'll try to
go for it
there was a request from someone
oh 41 not requesting qga
hard to play Queen's gamut accepted
when you're white and you play E4 maybe
at some point it's an opening I haven't
played much
um
okay we have a Petrov I don't know if my
opponent is intending Stafford
I wanna I wanna make things spicy though
let's play a boating
Bishop C4
so if takes I uh I play Knight C3
it's essentially a reverse staffer gamut
after he takes takes
it's Safford up a tempo
okay this will be interesting because
black playing the best move F6
uh this is
the only move to objectively keep some
Edge for black
and G6 is the best move as well
I've studied a little bit of this at
some point
like the idea is to play F5
to exert pressure as quickly as possible
again Ben offering me some fried rice
I'm not too hungry right now at least
for rice
more hungry for
attacking my opponent
yeah they do stuff like F5 and
I mean mainly Target G6 I think if I can
get rid of the g-pawn then Queen H5
could come
wow
I don't think I've seen this move before
I'm wondering if I can take
and taking walks into
D5
and there's a funny line takes takes
Queen H5 which should be great for white
it's actually force made for white
but takes and then D5
calculating takes
takes checking E7 I don't think that
really works
it's like I play G3
probably this move actually
and then after E4 play Queen D4
take and then take similar ideas that
previous game I played
sporting The Rook on the long diagonal
I mean G3 might accomplish the same
thing
but nice thing about this move it does
pressure the pawn once more
also considering Queen D5
but Queen D5 taken the queen E7
okay new position for me I've never seen
F5 before
but it looks uh looks nice
so I'm pretty sure this is
like much better for white
at least in in the lion E4 Queen D4
and there's two attackers in sapon and
zero Defenders
so at the very least I should be winning
the pawn back
thank you M1
xh1 first time Prime sub
okay Queen D4
foreign
there's a line that almost works for
black
Queen E7
after it takes
takes Rook G1
it's it's actually important that I'm
painting the bishop in the end
because there's cases Queen E7 King F2
there's no Bishop C5
oh the queen is even blocking the bishop
well multiple reasons why the bishop
can't develop
the C5
I'm also realizing
like a really Savage idea is after it
takes
I don't even need to take the Rook
immediately I could just Castle
and The Rook is still trapped
and then I'm
I'm threatening rookie one which
looks really really nice
I guess the one thing I'm allowing if I
do castles Bishop C5
rookie one king f8 take D6
Queen D4
Rook G8 9-up Exchange
so it's really a matter of deciding
between
[Music]
foreign
and taking the Rook immediately
I'm feeling castling though
because I think it's it's nicer to get
the king safer
and to get the rook in
I'm down a piece but uh
I'm guaranteed to win back material and
probably more so
on top of it
one of these practical decisions
foreign
is currently up a night and upon
but at the same time black has nothing
really developed
except a few Pawns
and yeah this line
I could take first or rookie one first
the line with her game one looks pretty
forcing
king of a take D6 Queen goes back it's a
rook Rook G and I take
this bishop really wants to join the
party
the problem is my Pawn's enough for us
so the bishop
it's a little bit blocked out
this could be another like very quick
game
depending what happens over the next
couple moves
any question earlier from emberg in
Reverse Stafford F6 Bishop C3
Oh you mean bc3
95 takes takes
I don't think that generally works
yeah like generally this tactic like it
almost works
I guess it doesn't matter which Pond
we're to take but if I were to go for
Queen H5 immediately and take it looks
like I'm winning The Rook but Queenie
seven would pin my queen
so
if I wanted to make that tactic work I
have to throw in like Bishop E3 or
casting to ensure my King's not on the
e-file
or the e-files blocked
but 95 is a very common tactical motif
[Music]
s
sometimes works
like famously uh this position after F6
then 95 works
okay if I take the crook
oh wow there's Queen there's Queen C no
Queen C5 I I just moved back
okay
might as well take
time flies
hey the jumper wood
stopping for 25 months
yeah welcome back
for everyone just joining
uh I've already been live for over two
hours
as the final 22 minutes of the rapid
Shield Arena
I don't think I'll be Crossing 2600 this
tournament
maybe time for just one or two games
after this one
fly's time
that move I didn't quite acknowledge
I have to still be careful
I mean I have Rook D1
if I play Rook F2 there's Queen E1 which
also still is probably okay
but then there's a line takes Queen E4 I
lose the bishop
so I'm leaning towards Rook T1 here
[Music]
let's go for this so when you rated
chess sweep Dennis organized a duck
chess game between me and IBC for mod in
his channel do you want to analyze the
game and find out who won oh
uh yeah feel free to whisper me a link
but of course it'll have to wait until
after this tournament
that sounds cool
oh did Dennis do commentary on it
sounds to be the case
a chess sweep is one of the um
the highest rated duck chess players now
might see him soon maybe we'll do some
like over-the-board Duck chess content
in real life
yeah this position is really not simple
because Queen C5
is maybe coming please fine
July is fine yeah
how many different variations are there
of time flies
okay I gotta Focus here
um because this is now officially a
threat if I take there's Queen E4
so maybe just uh Bishop D5
the bishop D5 allows Queen E2
but is that really a problem
also can I should calculate like Bishop
here here takes takes Rook E1
doesn't look great
yeah just Bishop D5
but Bishop G5 okay wait
oh losing some Focus
so Bishop D5 Queen E2 Bishop D2
threatening rookie one
let's just go for this
in the meantime I also do want to
capture the pawn so thank you Lucid
Chess Live
yes it's funny we're only 13 moves in
like we've both been spending a lot of
time
uh in the opening
okay finally
maybe getting a queen trade but this
yeah this simplifies things
I'm considering rookie one
also considering
no taking doesn't quite work
I'm taking out C6 doesn't work
yeah let's take the queen take the pawn
foreign
pond
[Music]
Rook wants to go here
Bishop wants to participate maybe I'll
play Bishop E3 first
I think the bishop is nicely placed on
F2
because there's cases rookie 197 then I
have Bishop H4
go for the double up
Bishop H4 is a looming idea
I think I'm I'm overthinking things too
much I should just be patient
h4h5
complete Bishop F3
foreign
of taking on E7
I still probably take
back on D4
oh
it feels close to traveling the bishop
now
threatening King H3
yeah the bishop is nearly trapped there
is G5
I have to watch out for a few different
moves here
we also play this move
I don't know why my Kings on H3
I was trying to trap the bishop I do
have Bishop G4
yeah it's all good
comment to take the Knight
uh maybe I missed my chance
you can take the Rook
I'm still interested in winning the
bishop somehow
or maybe just checkmating the king
okay let's close
check
play C4
now black is just paralyzed
maybe I'll go for the funny breakthrough
uh it's not quite a breakthrough though
still going for it hey it's a
breakthrough
got two connected passers
no mercy
okay let me try and Checkmate before
black flags
oh no my checkmates okay
an interesting game
I'm pretty sure things were under
control
most of that game was a little bit
tricky a five F5 is a mistake
another three only move
it's like yeah the other other ideas
don't quite work
we followed castings the best move
yeah pretty clean game actually
made a couple maybe I made a couple
blunders towards the end but held on to
the advantage
so that was a building kizeritsky Gambit
and that was a fresh line I haven't
really been aware of
we try and get into two more games
including this one
seeing your stream live is always an
awesome surprise thank you Eric oh thank
you Robin Spector
okay so finally got a ponziani I wonder
if the person who asked for it earlier
is still here
but um yeah black is playing a bit of a
dubious line
um
like Bishop C5 it was an attempt to
fight for the center but
it really just made
D4 stronger because it gained time on
the bishop
okay so developing happily
not doing anything too special so far I
mean H3 is a useful move in preventing
Bishop G4
and Bishop B6 of course would run into
D5
You'll Play Queen D2
like I might want to Castle Queen side
yeah way more often in ponziani New
Castle kingside
but I think in this case
there's so much attacking potential on
the king side
oh Vox really tempting me
I mean
I think I'll just rely on intuition
like take take
I'm threatening this now
also threatening this
hey thank you Alex bonzaya
shout out to Alex and Planet chess club
back to back reads
do appreciate that
if you're just joining I just sat at
peace
or
what should be a raging attack
this is one of the final games I'll play
in the rapid Shield Arena
it's an eight hour long term and I
joined
about six hours late
thank you Phila happy 30 months
I guess for everyone joining yeah we'll
do a recap of the opening
as my opponent thinks is ponziani
opponent um yeah play the an accurate
move
I develop
control the center
Castle queenside
and now
I mean there's really not too many ways
to defend here
there's only a handful of moves which
deal with this threat
like there's 97
okay rookie it is what was not one of
them
I mean I'm considering Knight G5 anyway
like do I need to take the Knight
I'll take the Knight because
I can always repeat and then play Knight
G5
key 795 it was too much fun here
I appreciate the DOT
Simon shampoo
and it's interesting that it said Dot
and not like point or period
or nothing
I don't see Force make
I'm thinking this first
Maybe
maybe just this first
so f610 95.
oh there's a nice meeting idea
expecting King G8 Queen F6 Knight E7
then Knight G5
threatening some other meat
oh yes
okay that was a nice ponziani win hope
people enjoyed that one
uh back to tournament
yeah it goes to show like
after misplaying the opening a little
bit even starting with this bishop C5
move
uh things can get difficult for black
very quickly
I've never gotten a shield
very rarely do I play in like a full
shield Arena but maybe I should make an
effort
I mean they have Shield arenas for
pretty much every type of chess
every variant too
playing this opponent if I played
oh this is a opponent who just resigned
before I even made a move
okay
we're playing
slightly questionable opening
I want to go for E4
I'm having none of this
Bishop C2 may be coming
of uh yeah let's
I'm gonna try and win this game quickly
so I get in one more game
position is still playable for white but
White's violated a lot of
opening principles so far
okay I'm gonna play this idea Knight E5
so this attacks and defends
also eyes at D3 Square
and this move
some idea to play B5
starting with B5
there's a line uh Bishop E2 G5
almost dropping the knights
okay white wants me to take so then I
get mated
that's interesting but okay I can just
Castle
[Music]
defend
I was hoping for some Greek gift
scenario not gonna happen though
yeah I'll put the Knight back
Queen E7
it's hard to develop with this structure
like the bishop and Knight are a bit
restricted
okay
almost dropped the bishop there
generally in these situations I don't go
over a queen trade
um because I'm trying to win quickly
but if queens were treated I opened that
file
okay I'm still trying to win quickly
some potential sock on G3
if Queen H4 I'll play Queen F5
it's hard to stop Queen F2
they got no mercy here
I think that we get in one more game
unless pairings yeah pairings are still
open
okay the goal is to uh
playing a decently
good player or higher rated player
I was going to say the goal is to win
the game before the tournament ends
so that requires require requires
playing super super aggressive chess or
it requires my opponent just not showing
up
okay can we get in one more game
uno mas
I break the top 30
okay
I mean berserk
I'm still trying to play hyper
aggressively
never played this opponent before
they have 15 seconds to move
okay Carol Khan I'll play two knights
attack
E6
G6 is a little bit dubious
[Music]
Bishop F4
I don't think this game is going to end
quickly but
I'm going for baroque
H4 probably coming soon
I'm going all in I want to play Queen
d3906 Queen H7 Maids
oh my Bishop oops
oh no
I was not expecting 95.
what have I done
oh that's a better move
take
if Knight takes Bishop I would have been
meaning by force
in this line it's it's getting
it's getting weird
it takes back
and I lose a bishop oh no my Bishop
oh wow
inside this move
What's Happening Here
wait
all right
left the game
but there's only 10 seconds left of the
tournament and 70 seconds left of them
needing to come back before they forfeit
oh no my opponent
okay so term is officially over
so
I should probably think about this
position because it's oh they're back
it's still really tricky
yeah I was thinking Bishops he's seven
there it takes takes
a very confusing position
both Queens are hanging
and if black takes I take then both
minor pieces are hanging
two also not to
not to mention
it's a fork but okay the Queen's hanging
first
oh no
I'm getting triple Forks and my [ __ ]
hanging oh no all my pieces
someone call an ambulance
yeah the thing is I'm playing like a
good player who clearly is going to see
my threat
so these Cheapo tricks don't quite work
in the same sense
uh I have this move
wait a minute
I think it's okay
it'd be really sad if black goes for a
draw here
the black might be able to force
repetition
and if I want to play for a win I might
have to
make a very irresponsible decision
I should actually yeah I should be
calculating
how to actually play for a win
and to play for when I have to basically
sack a piece
maybe a couple Pawns
there's actually a cool line
which maybe where'd my queen come from
yeah there's a chance we repeat and I
play Queen G3
maybe I should have considered playing
Knight F2 wait Queen G3 Knight F2 Bishop
D3
it's actually a cool line
each side of the chart of takes I take
with Brooker Pawn keep the bishop
defended takes takes
opponent left the game again this is
okay they have good internet
I mean the first several moves of this
game I was just playing
I was trying to play quickly trying to
win quickly and how
I'm in a spot where
it's not so simple I'm happy to see h6o
because it allows me to save the bishop
and I don't mind sacking the piece in
this fashion
yeah I was more scared of actually 95
9 repeating but
um
yeah maybe the signs also not so easy
if I play this there's takes Bishop T3
let's try it now Knight F6 I just take
wait what
uh ice that had to be a mouse Loop
but no mercy
what a weird finish to the game yeah
let's see wow engine just says equal
and then wait I was better oh I'm better
after Queen G3
yeah the square root of negative 2 but
actually how does that work Queen G3
Knight F2
ah same idea as I was okay
yeah so in this line
I allowed Knight D5 which apparently is
better for black but why is it better
I was going to take
ah that can safely take and then run
not so easy to go into though it was
black
anyway
um that's a tournament
I gained I gained a few rating points
had some fun games
if this goes on YouTube
and you made it this far let me know
your favorite moments or favorite game
I played 16 games total a few of these
games were
like non-games
but still had some fun moments